sky news has obtained cctv footage that
we understand to show ali harvey ali
walking to a london railway station on
the morning of the attack for more i'm
joined now by our crime correspondent
martin brunt who's in croydon for us
martin what can you tell us about this
cctv footage
police are examining it as we speak they
had it since saturday morning but it's
the first moving footage
of the suspect ali harvey alley and
it's film that captures him
on friday morning
near where he was staying in north
london
it's time stamped at 08 44 so at about a
quarter to nine on friday morning
he's alone he's wearing dark clothing
black trousers and a green parker style
type coat
he's walking well almost strolling along
doesn't appear to be in a hurry
it was filmed by a security camera
outside a supermarket and police believe
that it captures him on his way to catch
a train at gospel oak station
just over just over three hours
later and 50 miles away the suspect was
arrested at the scene of the murder of
essex mp sir david amos